COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY MAY
FOURTEENTH IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER. OF FUSION BISON AUDIO AND
VIDEO RECORDING OF TODAY'S
PROCEDURES PREMADE THIS ALSO
TELEVISED. AUTOMATIC SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY HERE
CUNNINGHAM HERE CARILLO FAIR
CERVANTES. FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER
GRAYSON. MAYES AREA PRESENT
SALAS. WALDRON. AND HAVE A.
BURGER. FELLA THANK YOU MISTER
VICE CHAIR FOR CONVENIENCE.
ABSENCE.
I WOULD HAVE.
THAT THAT'S. WHY WE'VE WE HAVE A
CORPSMAN WE HAVE A CONSENT
AGENDA IS OUR MOTION ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA?
WHO MEMBERS FOR CELLS SECONDED
BY MISTER CUNNINGHAM? AMEND
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
SPENDING TIME I CARILLO.
I REALIZED CERVANTES HIGH
CERVANTES AYE FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER
GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE MAYES NOSE
AREA.
BY NAZARIAN AYE SALAS SALAS AYE
WALDRON AYE WALDRON AYE.
THAT MOTION IS PASSED IN THE
SCHOOLS CLOSER. TO HIM VERY MUCH